il ya niveau vous est posée le défilé
numéro 5 et oui je sais je me suis rasé
depuis rappelons-le énoncés on a un
quadrillage régulier de 10 points sur 10
points
combien y at-il de carrés dont les
sommets sont des points du quadrillage
pour la petite histoire ce problème a un
petit peu changé ma vie ou en tout cas
ma perception des mathématiques
il s'agit d'un problème inventé par un
ami que mon ami et moi qui ont résolu et
que les professeurs avaient du mal à
risques au droit
c'est là que je me suis rendu compte que
les mathématiques c'est en fait un vaste
terrain de jeu on peut se poser plein de
nouveaux problèmes et que contrairement
à ce que l'éducation de mathématiques a
parfois tendance à suggérer les
mathématiques ne soit en fait absolument
pas un ensemble de faits à apprendre par
coeur ni un ensemble de savoir-faire
qu'il faut absolument être capable de
maîtriser
c'est grâce à ce problème que j'ai
découvert que j'aime les maths parce que
tout en étant la plus rigoureuse c'est
aussi la science la plus libre mais bref
revenons à l'énigme alors j'avais laissé
un indice sur le site de tedx saclay et
cet indice vous inviter à penser à
trancher je suis assez fier d'être
dispensé approché cet indice attirer
votre attention sur le fait que certains
carrés sont penchés comme celui là mais
avant de compter ses carrés je vous
propose de d'abord compter les carrés
par pencher
ces carrés peuvent être de dimension 1
par 1 2 par 2 ou ainsi de suite jusqu'à
n - 1 par rennes - 1 ou dans notre cas n
du nombre de points par côté du
quadrillage est égal à 10 e et parce que
le crâne en fait ils dépassent du
quadrillage combien y at-il de cars et
un par un on peut suivre le sommet en
haut à gauche pour répondre à cette
question
on a neuf position horizontale possible
et 9 position verticale possible du coup
le nombre de cars et un parent est égal
à 9 x 9 combien de quart et deux par
deux le sommet en haut à gauche à cette
fois 8 position horizontale possible et
8 position verticale possible il y a
donc huit fois huit cars et deux par
deux et les trois par trois vous voyez
qu à chaque fois que le côté du carré
augmente d'une unité le nombre de ses
position horizontale et verticale
possible diminue d'une unité
du coup il y à cette fois 7/4 et 3 par 3
puis 6 x 6 cars et 4 par 4 et ainsi de
suite jusqu'à 1 fois un quart et 9 par
neuf le nombre total de carre pas penché
n 9 x 9 + 8 x 8 + 7 x 7 et ainsi de
suite plus 1 x 1 et ça déjà c'est super
joli nombre de carrés dans un
quadrillage npar n est égale à la somme
des haines moisan premier carré alors en
maths on aime simplifier les formules
autant que possible et en fait on a une
très belle formule qui nous dit que la
somme des cas premier quart et c'est à
dire 1 ou carrés plus d'eau carré
puisque rocard et ainsi de suite jusqu'à
cas au carré est égale à la caf capucins
x 2 capucins / 6 et j'invite les plus
rigoureux parmi vous a démontré ce
résultat par exemple par récurrence dans
notre cas on n'a qu'à est égal à peine
moins 20 du coup la somme des aides -
après mikari est égale à la haine - fois
une fois deuxième en 1 / 6 et si je mets
n égalise dans cette formule
j'obtiens dispose 1 x 10 x 2 x 10.1 le
tout divisé par 6 ce qui est égal à 2
donc si vous avez répondu 285
félicitations votre raisonnement est
juste le seul problème c'est que vous
avez oublié
et pencher alors à priori l'écart est
penché ils paraissent dû raconter
sauf qu'on peut remarquer que tout car
épanché est inscrit dans un carré pas
penché mieux encore il tient dans le
quadrillage si et seulement si le carepa
pencher circonscrit tient lui aussi dans
le quadrillage encore mieux encore
étant donné un carré pas penché c'est en
fait assez facile de compter le nombre
de carrés pencher inscrit eh oui si on a
un carré cas par cas alors tout car
épanché inscrits est identifié par le
choix du sommet supérieur du carré
pencher et ce sommet supérieur est
forcément l'un des points du côté
supérieur du carré pas penché avec une
petite exception pour le cas où le car
est inscrit considérer est égal au quart
et humaine or le nombre de ses points
est facile à compter il est égal à la
longueur cas du côté du carré autrement
dit un carré pas penché cas par cas à
exactement cas carré inscrit on est
presque donc pour compte et où l'écart
et il nous suffit de multiplier les
nombre de carrés pas penché cas par cas
par le nombre cas or on a vu qu'il y
avait neuf fois neuf carrés de dimension
un par un
8 x 8 carré de dimension deux par deux
les plus généralement elle moins qu'à
fois n moins qu'à carhaix deux
dimensions cas par cas au final si je
commence par les grands carrés le nombre
total de carré et donc un au carré fois
neuf carrés inscrits dans des carrés pas
penché de dimensions 9 par neuf plus de
au carré fois huit cars est inscrite en
déclaré pas point cette dimension 8 par
8 + 3 ou 4 fois 7/4 et inscrits dans des
carrés pas bronché deux dimensions set
par set plus quatre carrés x 6 et ainsi
de suite jusqu'à 9 au carré voire est là
il suffit de faire cette longue
opération pour conclure mais comme un
match on aime avoir de jolies formules
je vous propose de faire un petit peu je
joue avec notre formule en fait notre
calcul correspond à une somme de termes
qui auront cette particularité d'être un
carré point un nombre qui est 10 - le
nombre qu'on a mis au carré de façon
plus formelle ce terme correspond donc à
la forme qu'a au carré fois elle monte
le nombre total de carré et donc la
somme des cas au carré voire elle
manquait alors ça c'est super cool parce
que ça va nous permettre d'écrire un
programme informatique qui va toujours
calculé le résultat peu importe la
valeur de m
sauf que si elle est égale à 1 milliard
l'ordinateur va commencer un petit peu a
ramé et sienne est égale un nombre comme
un google s'est complètement mort même
avec un ordinateur il faudrait plus de
temps que l'âge de l'univers pour que
l'ordinateur finisse son calcul fort
heureusement on peut simplifier notre
formule en développant le terme à
l'intérieur on obtient la somme des
haines fois cas au carré - chaos cube et
ça aussi on peut le séparer ce qui nous
fait la somme dnk carré - la somme des
cas au cube dans la première somme n est
un facteur commun à tous les n3 kkr et
on peut donc factoriser ce qui nous
donne n fois la somme des cas carré - la
somme des cas ou tubes or on a déjà vu
que la somme des cas au carré est égal à
elle moins 1 fois n fois 2e - 1 / 6 et
quid de la somme des cubes
eh bien on a deux formules super jolie
qui vont nous permettre de simplifier
tout ça na a occupe plus de au cube qui
est ainsi de suite jusqu'à n - en gros
cubes qui est égale à la somme des
entiers de 1 jusqu'à une mousse
le tout au carré et ça avec notamment
une formule découverte par goce dont on
a parlé dans l'épisode 5 sur l'infini
c'est égal à n x n moins diviser par
deux le tout au carré donc au final le
nombre total de carey est égale à une
fois n moins un fois n voix de zen - 1 /
6 - m² fois n - o car est divisé par
quatre et là on peut factoriser par
haine au carré fois une moison / 12 il
nous restera ensuite un terme en 2 x 2
et de moins en mois trois fois et de -1
donc ça c'est égal à 4 m - 2 - 3m +3 ce
qui nous donne n carré et fois n moins
une fois n + 1 le tout divisé par deux
et si on développe elle - fois une
puissante qui y est une identité
remarquable on obtient un carré fois m²
- 1
le tout divisé par 12 si ça c'est pas
joli il ne reste plus qu'à appliquer la
formule pourrait n'égalise ce qui nous
fait 100 x 90 9 / 2 qui est égal à 825
825 c'était ça la bonne réponse vous
avez été 1450 à répondre à ce défi les 5
on a eu trois cent soixante dix neuf qui
ont répondu 285 vers la réponse pour les
quarts et pas plonger dommage vous avez
oublié l'écart est reproché et et vous
avez été 337 à donner la bonne
prestation à vous maintenant on va
procéder au tirage au sort parmi ses 337
faites vous m que 254 être rentré en
lice pour pouvoir gagner les places pour
le tx5 est donc ce que je vais faire si
je vais sur random.org les jeux tirés un
nombre au hasard entre avec 254
expliquant que chaque nom et ceux ci un
numéro que j'ai bien fait gaffe à
enlever les doublons puisqu'un à qui ont
joué plusieurs fois le même bonne
réponse
mambé temps de jeu génère le résultat ça
me donne 231 231 cell
nous sommes qui nous quitte donc les
citations à toi tu es le grand vainqueur
des 2 places pour le thé xx e siècle et
le 30 novembre prochain
donc je t'enverrai un email pour te
donner tous les détails avec tout ça car
intérêt à venir me dire bonjour le 30
novembre pour les autres battant qui
expire qu' il y aura l'occasion de
refaire ça parce que j'ai trouvé ça bien
marrant et sans doute j'espère qu'à
l'occasion de gagner d'autres trucs et à
travers des défilés enfin avoir de vous
laisser je sais mais juste le fait que
la semaine prochaine ce ne sera pas
encore le début de la série sur
l'intelligence artificielle dans le dis
ça pour pas qu'ils trop de déçus mais la
semaine prochaine il y aura quand même
une petite vidéo qui seront un petit
complément à la série super démocratie
j'espère que vous serez encore là pour
le prochain défilé que vous fournirez
toujours plus de bonnes réponses